surprise rashida Jones is a mom it was
really fun that's right the 42 year old
welcomed her first child with boyfriend
Ezra Koenig months ago the actress and
daughter of famed music producer Quincy
Jones somehow managed to keep the baby
news a secret all while making the
rounds to promote her newest documentary
Quincy deaf how do you deal with your
ego and your art you have to do so big
bazooka bility dog but she's ever
fulfilled all those dreams
Jones and the 34 year old lead singer of
Vampire Weekend were first linked in
2016 though they have never publicly
confirmed to their relationship in July
2015
Jones stop by cohn eggs radio show and
dished about asking Robin Thicke to a
dance in junior high
his dad was on growing pains and my mom
was on Twin Peaks on ABC at the same
time so I met him at some ABC party and
we kind of like flirted and exchanged
numbers landlines obviously and I called
him and we've like talks on the phone a
lot and then I asked him to come to
junior high prom with me the director
was previously engaged to Mark Ronson
and was rumoured to be romantically
linked to John Krasinski Colin Jost and
Jon Favreau in the past in 2014 Jones
opened up to the Guardian about the
pressure women still face when it comes
to family and marriage quote I'm happy
but the fact that I'm not married and
don't have kids it's taken me a long
time to get to a place where I actually
am okay with that where I actually don't
feel like I'm some sort of loser
[Music]
[Applause]